this is Carl Franklin here from the
comfort of my kitchen I'm actually not
in Tahiti even though that's what this
scene would tell you it's a green screen
but I figured you know let's just all
imagine that we're on a beach hanging
out together drinking some cocktails
that have some fruit punch in them maybe
some rum maybe a little more rum maybe a
brought to us by beautiful people and we
got a band playing and you know I've
just told the band to take five so I can
talk to you so let's this we're just
imagining here this is what I'm hoping
will happen so let me share my screen
again and we'll get started so this
screen right here is is it's a
PowerPoint slideshow that I have that
I'm you know all my blazer code is
wrapped up in this thing I'm doing
called the Blazer desk show so don't
mind the subtle branding I just wanted
to say welcome in this hour I'm going to
share everything I know well almost
everything I know if I talk really fast
I'd be able to share everything I know
but it is it is an hour but this is the
thing that I want you to take away the
hands-on lab and the slideshow both of
those things are available at blazer
desk show.com so if you just go up there
you can actually download a pretty big
project that you can you know steal
snippets of code for you don't have to
worry about you know snapping
screenshots and URLs and all of that
stuff even though I put them here in the
slideshow so I'm gonna start by talking
about what blazer is blazer started as a
little web assembly project that Steve
Smith did right here at NBC but in Oslo
a couple of years ago and people just
went nuts they just went absolutely
crazy when they saw the possibility that
we could have c-sharp running in the
browser again and of course you know
everybody asks the question is this
silverlight v next and the answer is no
it's not
I actually wrote a little blog post
about it which you can see I got a link
here the difference between web assembly
and Silverlight and I can understand why
people conflate silver lights past with
Blazer web assemblies future it's
because that they both kind of have the
same end result right they both allow
developers to write c-sharp code that
runs in the browser but the difference
is so vast and it's so different okay so
here's the difference Blazer ultimately
failed because I'm sorry Silverlight
ultimately failed because of the plug-in
model of the browser which was really
the only way that we could have code
that wasn't JavaScript running inside
the browser the plug-in model was
causing all sorts of problems for iOS
and most notably flash was draining the
batteries of iPhones and iPads because
it was so CPU intensive and it was also
the plug-in model was also a vector for
malware and so for the first time you
know Apple customers we're experiencing
malware and of course they dogged on
Microsoft for years about being you know
just insecure and all of that stuff and
they prided themselves because of that
App Store model on curation and you know
strict standards and stuff you can just
run an app that you download off the
internet so anyway Steve Apple Steve
Jobs he said and essentially a blog post
that was called thoughts on flash that
no more iOS no more plug-ins in iOS so
iPhones iPads they would that the Safari
Browser would not use and wouldn't
load plugins any plugin so Silverlight
was a casualty of that now webassembly
which is just a couple years old is this
binary virtual machine that's
cross-platform that lives in every
browser and I'm talking every browser
okay not every browser because there's a
lot of browsers that they were popular
for a while and then for whatever reason
development stopped on them right
Internet Explorer being one of them so
even the latest version of Internet
Explorer which is 11 doesn't support web
assembly because they just stopped
developing for it right but every other
browser and especially the ones that you
use today even yes even Safari on iOS
they all support web assembly so that is
sort of the the backstory of web
assembly and that became the backstory
of blazer but along the way Steve
Sanderson and Co essentially developed
this component model and the component
model is really what blazer is all about
because when you write markup and code
for blazer that same markup and code can
run in two different hosting models one
of them obviously web assembly runs in
the browser but the other one is a
server-side blazer which runs all the
code on the server which is interesting
right as it's sort of an answer to web
forms I guess you could say but the
difference is gonna be really obvious
when we start looking at the traffic and
looking at the magic behind how that
same code is going to run that runs in
web assembly is also going to run on the
server so you really have to pick a
horse but I'm gonna show you a technique
by which you can belay that decision and
actually develop both hosting models at
the same time
so you really don't want to nor can you
nor would you want to combine models
alright this is a spa framework so this
is a single page application UI
framework like angular like react and
you wouldn't pick like a version of
angular where all the JavaScript ran on
the server versus on the client and mix
them like that's what we're talking
about here you wouldn't mix them it's
really a UI framework it's not an
architecture for building a spa
application the only part of that
architecture that's different is where
that code is running everything else
will be exactly the same alright so now
that I've got the what is it out of the
way let me talk about how to install it
well if you just install the latest
Visual Studio 2019 not preview not
anything and regular dotnet core 3 oh
you're gonna get blazer server support
right in the box that has been baked
since core 3 o was shipped but web
assembly is still in preview and if you
want to run web assembly you need to get
the latest version of Visual Studio 2019
preview even the free Community Edition
is just fine you don't need to spend any
money but you guys are probably all
professional developers you probably
have MSDN and you probably have
Enterprise that's just fine but the
Community Edition does everything that
you need to do you install the latest
dotnet core SDK 3.1 alright and then you
install the Blazer web assembly template
and it's a command line thing that you
just run and if you just Google blazer
or web assembly blazer web assembly
getting started or web assembly preview
3 now available that will also show you
exactly what you need to do to install
it
all right so what I'm gonna do is talk
about the server-side model and then the
client-side model but we're not just
going to talk we're gonna actually look
at the network traffic and see what it
is so the model is for server the magic
that makes this happen is signal our I'm
just going to go over to my code and
create a blazer application I'm going to
call this blazer server and let's get
the right location here so because I've
installed the template I have the option
of also doing a web assembly version and
hey if you've installed the template and
you have and you don't see this there's
a little trick that I just learned
yesterday or the day before
switch back to dotnet core 3 Oh with
this drop down and then back to 3 1 and
you should see it the latest version of
Visual Studio 2019 preview is still a
little wonky but there's workarounds so
blaze of server app is what I'm going to
create we're just going to run the the
application because there's a little
demo built into the template and you'll
get to see what that looks like you've
probably seen this and yet this is
another issue just sometimes you'll have
to run it twice you might have to build
it it's nothing to worry about just
Visual Studio and the other thing I
wanted to say about webOS the
webassembly version is that it is
syntactically baked right now
the syntax of the component model isn't
going to change between now and when
webassembly ships so you can be safe
arrest assured that when you build your
blazer web assembly code that that code
is going to run the underlying plumbing
code might change a little bit alright
but that is going to be baked in may
and then webassembly is going to be part
of dotnet 5 shipping in November so I've
got a counter button this is one of the
three demos here here's some static
information here's a counter but notice
that it also reset to zero when I
navigate it away from it that's going to
be important later and then I've got an
example of fetching data from either a
service that's local or an API if we're
using the the webassembly template so
let's just look at this code while it's
running I'm gonna go to my pages folder
and you see counter dot raiser so that
is a blazer component that is actually a
page and you can tell it's a page
because it has the at page at the top
with the route so you can see here I've
got very simply some HTML HTML here HTML
here this @ sign this razor syntax you
should be already if you've done any
kind of razor you should be used to that
we're displaying this variable but the
variable is defined in this code block
right here in the page yes you can move
it out to another class but it's right
here in the page and we've got this
variable right here current count and a
method increment count that just yep
increments it we get there with this
button and the @ sign tells you and
Blaser that this is a blazer server side
whatever Co a blazer component model
directive it's not if I took away that @
sign that would be a JavaScript unclick
right here right so that's
a JavaScript directive this is a blazer
directive so there's no run at equals
server there's nothing it's very very
concise and I love this about the
component model is that it just works so
so well but as you can see I could put a
breakpoint here and when I click the
button boom I got the breakpoint now
this code is running on the server wait
a minute this is the client this is the
server right so I've defined the mark-up
but this code is running here how did
that happen well let's take a look
by pressing our friendly f12 button and
I'll go to network I'm gonna disable the
cache you could probably see right there
just make sure there's no caching
happening and I'll start recording and
then I'll press control f5 and we'll see
what we get all right so that is all of
the HTML CSS JavaScript whatever that
was sent down but look at this guy right
here and I know you can't see that but
that's a WebSocket this is signal R this
is essentially a signal our connection
and where it came from is defined here
in this blazer server JavaScript that
runs in the browser
all right that's sent to the browser and
that hooks the Dom elements and then
when I click the button that hook
happens and it says oh this is a server
directive that I need to call it sends a
message via signal R to the server the
server says oh on click increment count
I'm going to run that server runs that
and look this affects the Dom how do I
know
well the server has a graph of the
clients Dom in memory every single
client it keeps the graph of the Dom so
there's no viewstate going back and
forth like there was with web forms it
already has a graph it knows what the
state of the Dom is so it notices that
there's a difference
and it says uh well I'm gonna take the
diff and whatever changes I'm gonna send
a binary message back down to the
browser to update the Dom and all of
that stuff happens now how do we know
that well let's let's click on this and
we'll actually see the messages as I
click right there you can see two
hundred and ninety bytes went up to the
server that's the green arrow 148 bytes
came down and then 27 bytes I'm assuming
this is a thank you very much I got it
everything is updated you know maybe
this is another the latest graph the Dom
I don't know what that is actually but I
do know how you can find out if you want
to see
I have a blog post here and you can just
go to blog at Phoenix comm or look in
this the PDF which is linked at the
hurts the server for this link I'll show
you how to log the signal our traffic
and actually look at it and see what's
going on not just the not just the
amount of data but look at this look at
look at how much data was transferred
initially when i refresh that page 146 k
that is pretty cool alright so just I
want you to just see what's going on
here this is the magic the magic is
happening with signal R now that's
signal our hub that is being used here
isn't something that you can tap into
it's not something that you can hook
yourself to do your own kind of you know
chat rooms or other typical signal are
applications but this is just a and the
asp net 3 1 cor core 3 1 web application
excuse me
so you can hang on second
so you can add a signal our capability
to it and it isn't going to interfere
with this one so this signal our hub
that's built into dotnet core 3/4 blazer
server applications is just a one to one
I mean there's a hub but it's only
allowing one to one communication
between you the client and the server so
there isn't any one too many stuff going
on here and it's very tightly controlled
and you don't have access to it for good
reason so let's talk about scaling
because obviously if everything is on
the server there's gonna be a certain
amount of memory required for every
client and it turns out it's about 85 K
right now our last time I looked anyway
so it's not a whole lot but you know if
you're planning on supporting 20,000
users you might have to beef up the
memory in the CPU of your of your server
so you don't want to keep millions of
rows of data in memory for every user
just this is standard stuff when you're
thinking about conserving memory so you
do have overhead per client WebSockets
is another precious resource that will
run out eventually based on the amount
of memory and CPU available but what you
can do is you can scale out with this
signal our service let me pull this over
here so azure has a signal our service
and you can use that and completely
remove signal R from your server to to
scale out
and there's this this github has all the
magic tools for doing that so this right
here is a screenshot from a presentation
Dan Roth did dotnet conf and they did a
test Microsoft did a test for
appropriate latency which they deemed
was less than 200 milliseconds you know
added for handling the UI under a load
and this was a real application it
wasn't just a counter they built an
application and they wanted to automate
clicking the buttons and seeing what the
latency was as they turned up the number
of users so it turns out with oops
all right well with anyway with one
virtual CPU and three-and-a-half gigs of
RAM in their virtual in their you know
set up here they were able to support
about five thousand active users if they
up that to a force virtual CPU server
with 14 gigs of ram 20,000 now that was
without using signal art service as your
signal our service that was just in the
box so memory is the primary bottleneck
I'll talk in a minute about having
multiple servers or a server farm or a
cluster in what's required for that
so let's talk about the ups and downs
the drawbacks the benefits and the
drawbacks of Blaser server hosting model
download size is small the app takes
full advantage of the server because
it's all running on the server so
anything that you can do in an asp net
core application you can do on the
backend thin clients are supported so
web assembly is if web assembly isn't
running in that particular browser time
so I'm looking at you Internet Explorer
11 there is actually a required polyfill
to get it to work with Internet Explorer
11 but that's easily solved some
companies are still using that because
it isn't modern and because their
software isn't modern so this may matter
to some people the apps c-sharp c-sharp
code base is not sent to the clients so
they can't see the code that's running
my answer to that is that's actually not
a benefit nor is it a drawback it just
is the the rule for me is I don't put
anything on the client that I don't want
the client to see and that's true
whether it's JavaScript or blazer or
whatever
so the downsides of blazer server
there's a little latency added for the
round trip to signal are for that signal
art hub there's no offline support so if
the client connection fails the app
stops working
right that's kind of a big deal so
remember every UI interaction requires a
trip to the server and then scalability
we just talked about that memory state
is what makes this possible and we'll
talk about that in a minute and an
answer peanut core servers required to
serve the app so you can't just package
it all up like you can with HTML and
JavaScript and serve it on a CDN
all right I'm gonna switch over to what
do we call this slide oh and see if
anybody's got any questions that's apt
SLI dot dough or SLI dot dough
there's a link in the channel room
conference stream room one
any questions on server-side Blazer or
does anybody want to just unmute their
microphone and ask a question that'll
work too
alright I'll take that as a no let's
move on if you have any questions again
you can just unmute your mic and talk or
I'm watching slide Oh as well all right
so let's talk about the client-side
hosting model it's a little simpler
because everything's just running in the
server there isn't a client-server
interaction there is no signal our hub
for basic UI
of course you know if you're gonna do
your call into api's you're gonna do
that no matter where you're calling from
but so as I said before web assembly is
the thing that makes this all possible
it's there it's in the browsers it's not
going away
it's not insecure it has the same
security boundaries for your code that
JavaScript has and dotnet isn't the only
language that runs on webassembly rust
runs on web sembly golang runs on web
assembly there's a growing list of
languages that have compilers for web
assembly you think of this like a little
virtual machine it's its own operating
system there's even an initiative to
move web assembly out of the browser and
on to the desktop which requires now an
interface to the system that it's
running on and that's called Wasi Wasi
dot dev if you want to go there and keep
your eyes on that I think that web
assembly is so revolutionary and so
solves the problem that we've always had
with the browser which is JavaScript
JavaScript is by nature a problem for
enterprise developers and was written in
a weekend and there's parts of it that
really suck and you know there's a lot
of people out there that use it just
because it's the only game in town
well web assembly sort of blows the
doors off of that and says you know what
there's a lot of other languages that
you can run in the browser now with the
same level of security and an efficiency
I heard a rumor I don't know if this is
true but somebody told me that the guys
who built docker said if they had
webassembly in 2008 they never would
have built it
interesting huh all right so there's the
model we're gonna go back and watch the
traffic with a webassembly application
which I will just add to this solution
I'm gonna have a blazer application I'm
going to call it blazer wasm and here's
here's the old trick again see
webassembly isn't showing up I'm gonna
do that also I'm going to check this off
right here asp net core hosted what is
the advantage of using blazer at all it
is slower than Laz emit overloads the
server's and it doesn't have cool
features that JavaScript has like
support and you know I get this a lot
you know why not just use JavaScript man
I'm not telling you not to use
JavaScript I'm not talking to you so
right on with your angular and your
JavaScript and everything go for it just
use it all right so this blazer is for
four people for developers for
corporations that have more c-sharp
resources than JavaScript resources or
maybe they've found that getting people
up to speed on all the JavaScript
frameworks and all the libraries and the
tooling and all that stuff they have a
lot of attrition they have a lot of
people that can't do it and only a few
that rise to the top and then those
people get hired out so so there's
definitely a shortage of programmers but
there's a lot of enterprise developers
that ever since Silverlight that went
away have been looking for a way to
leverage their skills on the web so I
think that's the largest audience for
for for blazer but good question
anonymous all right so as peanut core
hosted is not a option that I'm checking
off here if I don't check that off I get
one application that just you know
Visual Studio runs and is expressed to
the client but I want a server also in
that same URL space so I can do
controllers and things
so that's what this gives you
so look at this looky here I've got a
blazer wasm server which again is a
server it's got controllers for API
controllers and it hosts this client
right here this is going to run in the
browser but they both have access to
this shared project which is just a
dotnet standard project and this is got
the models so this is where you would
put your models if you're using this
kind of architecture so let's look at
blazer wasm and I'm going to set blazer
wasm server as the startup project I'm
also going to rebuild this because I
know better and we'll run it we're gonna
see it it looks very similar in fact the
the code is almost exactly the same but
the difference is this fetch data right
here in the blazer server version this
is calling a local service forecast
service which is injected into the page
and it lives here on the server in a
data folder and it's just returning some
data but on the client fetch data uses
an h2
client and it calls a URL now it's a
local URL it's a relative URL but that
is the server calls into blazer wasm
server to the weather forecast
controller and this is an API controller
so the difference is architectural but
the code is is exactly the same
especially for the counter so speaking
of the counter I'll go here and I'll do
a breakpoint
and there you go this is new just in the
last few days now you can debug but
there are some limitations there's
there's a few debugging limitations if
you go out to that blog post that's
linked on the first page the getting
started and what's required Dan Roth
tells you exactly what those limitations
are debugging isn't complete yet but at
least you can you know you can get there
you can get breakpoints things there are
things that you can't inspect though and
things that you can't do all right so
I'm going to continue here let's do what
we did before with the server go to the
network tab disable the cache there we
go control f5 and let's see everything
that gets loaded up here whoa a lot of
stuff
six megabytes transferred yes that's a
lot and that is because by default in
debug mode the linker is turned off and
if the linker is turned on you won't get
the entire wasm framework and that
framework by the way is right here the
CLR is called dotnet laz 'm let me
expand this a little bit so you can see
the size
and the framework the thing that's
actually taking up the most space is ms
not ms core lib but where is it went on
five sort by size you'll see yeah ms
core live dll that's right 1.3 megabytes
so if I turn off and I can turn it off
by going to release mode if I or I turn
on the linker if you're in release mode
the linker is on
you
and we'll do the same thing again
control f5
all right now it's about a megabyte so
big difference if you're if the linker
is on but look these are all DLL so that
dotnet wasm is the CLR that is the in
it's based on mo no it's animo no based
CLR that is the binary whereas all of
the other code that runs our assemblies
and their dotnet to standard assemblies
which means a lot a lot of stuff
obviously you can't do anything that
calls out to Windows or to a system but
all the good stuff that you need to do
UI is in there and anything that's
missing you can just add a new get
package too and as long as it's dotnet
to standard compliant it's going to run
so benef
it's and drawbacks of this model the
code executes more quickly in the
browser so there's lower latency because
we don't have to go to signal are just
for basic UI interactions you do have
offline support and progressive web apps
are are supported and you even saw that
when I created a blades or web assembly
application there's a checkbox to enable
PWA support so that adds the manifest
and it adds the serviceworker and you
can just go ahead and modify that to
your heart's content based on what PWA
does also because it doesn't require
that server to exist can be distributed
via CDN and as I said before any dotnet
standard to a c-sharp will run in the
browser so downsides you can't directly
access your database just like
JavaScript you wouldn't send in down in
JavaScript a connection string to a
sequel database or a secret that's used
a password that's used to access Asha
resources you're not going to do that in
that code you're going to have to write
an API layer so use the API you call the
API from the clients in the API you can
do whatever you need to do to kick off
whatever processes on the server so it's
still in preview it'll actually be in
preview until dotnet 5 but it will be
baked plumbing wise in May right now as
I said before the the component model is
baked the component model isn't going to
change the syntax isn't going to change
so your code is shipped to the client
just I have to mention this because
somebody brought this stuff is a
security concern it's no more security
concern than with JavaScript so you
wouldn't run secret code you wouldn't
run your secret sauce but you have an
option you can run that in an API on the
on the backend
all right other questions about blazer
webassembly hosting model we got a whole
bunch of questions in slide outs so
let's see would you recommend blazer for
production usage say deployment to Azure
app service well the I have to ask you a
question which which blazer right now I
wouldn't put blazer webassembly in
production but I would recommend blazer
server but here's the thing you now know
the difference between blazer server
hosting model and blazer webassembly
hosting model we've talked about the
pros and cons so now let's talk about
where it's appropriate to use blazer
server I think that for enterprise
developers who are doing business to
business software business to customer
software need to think about how many
obviously how many clients they want to
support at the same time and either make
sure that they have one big server with
jus gunda memory and CPU to handle that
or that they think about building a
cluster which now raises other questions
about scale in in-state right so we're
going to talk about state in a minute
but that has to definitely be handled
you have to manage your state and while
the tools there are primitive they're
easy to understand but you there it
isn't like session in web forms where
you have like this prescriptive system
that you can either store it outside in
a server or in a sequel server it's
essentially up to you you have classes
and those classes can be serialized to
JSON and then stored wherever wherever
you want to store them you want to store
in the sequel server or in a cosmos DB
and spend all that money go for it but
you probably want to think about maybe
some of it in local storage right in the
browser and some of it
outside on a document database or
something that's a lot less expensive
but get it outside of your application
that's what you're going to need in
order to do webform kind of stuff so if
you can support that and you can count
on the fact that your customers are
using it in a in a scenario where you
can count on the bandwidth right that
would be good
I don't know as if this would be good
for a Starbucks app you know what I mean
where you know what I'm saying like you
would the PWA with Blaser server not a
good idea
because you don't have the offline
support and all of that stuff you have
to be connected so think about those
restrictions and if you can check off
all those boxes and Blaser server seems
to fit then yes I would recommend it for
production I have this question long so
I'll split it for the web assembly
solution there will be some delay when
you run the app for the first time yes
that's right server version does not
have this drawback yes that's also right
is this possible to make your
applications start running on the server
then all the assemblies are downloaded
in the background and when they're ready
the app switches to the web assembly
does that make any sense I'm not so sure
it's a big deal like I mean what what
are you gonna where are we talking about
up to five Meg's up to six megabytes of
data Gmail is five megabytes in an
initial download and it is an initial
download it goes into cache and just
like with Gmail you can clear the cache
and when next time you go you're gonna
wait for a few seconds for it to load up
again so I don't think it's a I don't
think it's a big deal I mean any of
these spot frameworks angular react they
all have the same issue which is there's
a whole bunch of stuff that has to get
loaded the first time
but you know there are situations like
for example if your preferable model is
webassembly
and but you need to rely on the server
version for Internet Explorer 11 in
things like that yes you could do that
you could fall back to the server
version but you know it would be a
different URL and all of that stuff so
you have some things to think about can
Blaser be used in it as an isolated
module in an existing asp net solution
without framing it yes you can add
blazer pages to any asp net 300 blazer
server pages to any asp net 300
applications easy peasy
all right let's move on
questions guys so let's talk about
binding binding is very very elegant in
this component model they've done a good
job of making events very easy to
understand and I'm gonna show you what
that looks like now
rather than sort of reading the screen
to you this is just a sort of a
reference let's actually do this here so
I'm going to go back to Blazers server
as being my startup project here and
let's go to index raiser
making sure this is all happy and isn't
gonna barf on me make sure we're back in
Blazers server
oh yeah I was in release mode let's go
back to debug mode
you
you're gonna get this a lot squiggles
that go away in Visual Studio all right
cool so I've got I think I've got in my
toolbox some snippets yes
yes I do so let's use these well
I guess I it's a complete snippet
alright so let's talk about binding
you've already seen one-way binding in
the counter page right this is one way
meaning you're just displaying something
the two-way binding is where you have
input so now I'm binding this input tags
default property which happens to be
value that's why I'm not I don't have to
be explicit with that if it's the
default property I'm binding it to
message which is this property right
here and then I'm displaying that
message in the top
this
it's in the input and it's also in that
h1 right there now if I change it I'll
type changed there's an event that
triggers the UI update by default it's
on change which happens when we lose
focus so I'm gonna hit tab boom and that
unchanged event happens that's what
tells a blazer to update the binding
update the the values on the page but I
can change that event I can say at bind
yeah
bind : event equals on input and that
happens with every keystroke so now
every keystroke is going to update the
UI there it is so one simple change and
this event is now forcing that UI update
now let's do something interesting and
let's add a component I'm gonna add a
component into my shared folder this is
where shared components go or non pages
and you know this is just a convention
right so I'm going to say I'm on a new
razor component and I'm going to call it
child component
and you're gonna see one of the latest
Visual Studio previews best features uh
yeah not really that's gonna hang there
forever so the workaround is just close
it reopen it again and we'll replace
this with this particular code right
here so this is a component doesn't have
an app page directive at the top and
I've just got some inline styling here
with a div I'm giving it some padding a
like gray background color so that we
know visually that it's a component and
I've got a parent message string
property here and that I'm displaying
there and when I click the button we're
going to call update message and update
message is going to raise an event so
let's talk about parameters all
components when they interact with their
host they interact via parameters so the
parent message parameter think of it
like a public property on a custom
control but it's it can be bound to and
it can be updated and all of that same
with the event so this event callback I
pass it you know whatever the type that
I wanted to raise and I called it
message changed and this is essentially
an event an event definition now I'm
going to raise it when I click the
button I'm going to set the parent
message to blaze on and then call a
message changed invoke async and by the
way any method can be async just put
make it async task instead of void and
then I can do things with a weight so
I'm invoking this and passing the parent
message now back in the host I'll change
this code
and here I've got the same binding with
bind event on input but now I'm defining
a child component and I'm binding the
parent message property to my message
property all right so when my message
property changes the parent message is
going to change when the parent message
changes from below my message is going
to change it's a two-way binding and by
the way the event that is going to cause
the change in the print in the component
is message changed so when the message
changed event gets raised my message
will get changed and then it will be
changed here and here
so look how slick that is I didn't even
need to have an event handler and to set
values I just used binding right changes
up here changes in the component and
when I change it from the component boom
it changes me in the parent elegant
elegant elegant elegant beautiful love
that so let's talk about handling state
this is absolutely critical if you want
to do a sort of a cluster application
right which is an economic way to scale
out rather than having one jageun de
server but let's talk about first
getting state out of the page and then
we'll then we can actually move it out
of the application but that's beyond the
scope of what I'm talking about but
you'll see just how easy it is
so in Blazer server I'm just going to
add a class and I could do this in place
or client as well but we'll just pick
server app state doesn't have to be
all appstate I'm just calling a nap
state it has one property called counter
and now I want to add this as a service
that I can access anywhere in my
application and to do that this is in
startup and configure services I'm gonna
add it as a scope service what's the
difference between singleton let's say
in scope well singleton services of
which the weather forecast services one
there's one instance that's shared among
all clients all right not good for state
because it has to be a client by client
access instance that's what scoped is so
when you add scoped now you're saying I
need an instance of app state for every
single client so this actually manages
the instantiation part of it and now you
can just inject it where you want it and
whatever that instance is that's what
you get so I call at inject app state
app state in the counter and here I can
get completely get rid of this
and I can use appstate dot counter not
sure why this is a little bit brain-dead
right here and not giving me
intellisense but I got a feeling if I
just rebuild this or build the solution
everything's going to be fine
yeah work just fine Visual Studio has a
little catching up to do but again this
is a preview version of Visual Studio
2019 so as I said before I remember when
I incrementing the counter and I went
back to home and or off the page and
then back to the page
it had initialized to zero that's
because the page reinitialize is on on
on navigation so just by moving this
outside you know into a scoped service
now I've moved it out of the page
so what do I put in here anything
whatever you want so this is all stuff
that you want to persist you know this
is your new session if you will or any
scoped service you can consider it
session based you know this is something
that'll be available client by client
now in the server what happens if that
server goes down what happens if they
press refresh well it's completely gone
but you can use it's not here you can
use stuff like local storage to store
stuff locally in the browser per client
and then of course you can use some
database or anything like that there is
a great shopping cart demo that I have
in a blog post you can check out and
this shows you how to use local storage
to persist state and it's just a little
shopping cart demo that I did where you
pick an item you get to see the item you
put in a quantity you add it and then it
shows you what's in your cart and then
if you close the app and go away and
come back within 30 seconds because
that's the default time it will still be
there in the cart and you can obviously
change that from 30 seconds to whatever
you want it's just really to show you
that you can put a little bit of stuff
in local storage if you want to but
Steve Sanderson says anything really
more than a couple of K you probably
should move that to a data store
somewhere all right so this is the
coolest thing it looks like the last
thing that I'm going to show you which
is a technique Steve Sanderson showed at
NDC London earlier this year to develop
both the client and server apps
simultaneously so I've got both a client
and a server app in my project right
here and the first thing I'm going to do
is add a project reference from Blaser
server project reference to blazer wasm
client in blazer wasm shared alright
from the server to the client not to
this server but this is where the code
is it's in blazer wasm client that's why
I want to do that now if I go into my
servers underscore host CS HTML this is
sort of the HTML shell that everything
runs in you can see that there isn't
much here in the body this right here is
for handling errors here's the script
this is everything right there that is
this right there is your entire set your
compiled blazer components all your
pages your components your code all of
it is right there so instead of using my
local app I'm going to use blazer wasm
client app and now what's going to
happen is when I run the server it's
going to run on the server and all the
code will run on the server except the
code is this code the code that's in
Blazer wasm client so when it'd be cool
if I could run them both at the same
time well I can do that by going to the
solution properties and I'm gonna set
Blazers multiple startup projects
Blazers server to b1 and blazer wasm
server remember because that is hosting
that guy and just to show you that this
is working I'm going to make the crazy
step of deleting the pages from my
server-side blazer app and also I want
to change the mode to server not
pre-rendered pre-rendering means that
it's a it's a server-side thing only and
pre-rendering means that it renders
twice once before it connects to your
pages ari
render once before they connect to the
client and then once after and I want
that so now I'm going to rebuild the
solution and we're obviously going to
move questions offline because I've only
got four minutes here but after the
solution is rebuilt I can run this and
we're going to get two browsers
you
right one is running on
server blazer server right there you can
see and one is running on the client
blazer wasm but it's both of these are
the client code now is it going to work
remember I told you the difference
between fetch data this one calls an API
with a relative URL this one calls a
service but now it's running on the
server it's got a problem it doesn't
know where that service is not only that
but it doesn't have an HTML and HTTP
component so it's going to complain
about that first
there's no registered service of type
HTTP client so in order to get this to
work you have to do two things you have
to inject are not inject but you have to
add HTTP client to this to the
server-side environment and when you go
into the code for fetch data you can't
use a relative path here so the actual
path is here in launch settings JSON on
blazer wasm server we get that ssl port
right there and now we can go back to
fetch data and change this to http local
hosts : this guy weather forecast and
now it should be able to call the API
from both sides
all right here's blazer client
oh now blazer client has a problem and
it's probably just because I got to
rebuild everything this happens a lot
you know when you're when you're
developing just rebuild usually solves
problems that don't
you
here we go so on the client
on the server now I can fetch data also
and folks that is going to be it for me
because I've got one minute to spare but
I'm gonna take questions outside I'll
meet you in the hallway but I'll also be
in slide oh okay thank you very much
and thanks to NDC for helping make this
happen in hi Mads torgeson
you